we did a crazy panel to 6500 people yep
without 6500 exactly and now we're gonna
have an insane concert on this gorgeous
day in San Diego and everyone got
lightsabers I think sharing it you know
there's there's so much there was so
much preparation time and and an
introspection and how do I do this and
you know what can I bring to it and
talking with JJ and filming it but
sharing it with everyone finally I think
that's that's probably the most special
part of the whole thing
yeah he said I think we have a chance to
continue a legacy and continue it well
and pay respect but at the same time go
off on a new adventure obviously we've
asked the new characters so it's a great
balance of both for them very very happy
to be a part of this I had heard about
comic-con before I even knew what it was
like it's just a point of reference and
obviously we started with celebration
which was a massive thing just for Star
Wars and then to come here which
celebrates so many amazing things and
then be able to be in Hall H and kind of
have as much interaction as possible
with the people that are gonna see the
film is an amazing thing and then you
know the reaction when Harrison came on
stage and really feeling the completion
of the whole thing you know I was
amazing it was a standing ovation and
and just to see how well I've been for
him it was very generous of him to to
come here for the fans and it was great
hey there's my second time being at
Comic Con but it's nothing like my first
and it's just so great to be exposed to
fans who are so passionate about Star
Wars and so passionate about the
characters and who I'm very very excited
to be open up into a into a new story so
yeah it was kids there is a Symphony
Orchestra about to perform the music of
Star Wars to 6500 band with lightsabers
as the Sun Goes Down it sounds amazing
yeah and we all can't wait to see it oh
yeah
you